well the more medication you're on the
harder it is to keep up right or take
things properly so southwest medical is
back to share some advice on taking
medication
the way you're supposed to take a look
so we're talking medical adherence what
does that mean
well surgeon general c everett coop once
said drugs don't work
in patients who don't take them we call
this medication adherence which means
taking your medications the way you're
supposed to
the full benefits of medications are
often not realized because people don't
take their medications
as prescribed and why is it important
for people to be open and direct
in talking with their health care
professionals about the medications and
supplements
they're actually taking using
prescription drugs over-the-counter
medications and
vitamins or supplements at the same
times can cause your prescriptions to be
ineffective or dangerous sometimes
for example antibiotics or
anti-inflammatories such as ibuprofen or
aspirin can cause serious bleeding when
used with blood thinners
using some pain medications with alcohol
or certain other drugs like xanax or
valium
increases the risk of overdose or death
doctor what are some of the reasons why
people do not take their medication the
right way
there may be many reasons that people
don't take their medications
as prescribed some people may not be
convinced the medication is working for
them
some people are concerned or fearful of
side effects or having difficulties
taking their medications especially
when they have to self-inject or use an
inhaler some people cost is a factor
and sometimes people just forget and
what ways can
your provider help with this well
healthcare is a team effort
so it's important to talk to your doctor
and pharmacist
and share your concerns with them and
more importantly ask questions
it's good to keep an updated list of
your medications
and take it with you to each of your
doctor's appointments and let's talk
about more benefits for the medication
checkup
medication checkup is pretty easy but it
can have big benefits
it can help you to find possibly
dangerous combinations you may be taking
identify improper dosages or mistakes
you may be making
you may also ask about side effects the
correct time and sequence to take each
of your medications and supplements
and what drugs could be taken with or
without food
this review of your medications can also
help simplify your daily regimen by
identifying medications
you may not need to take anymore or by
recommending an extended day supply
which means you can get a 90
or 100 day supply of medication
depending on your insurance
each time when you fill them you will
have a refill of your medication less
frequently
and what are some of the options that
southwest medical patients have
at southwest medical we have an
electronic medical record that you can
access
online or with a telephone app by
accessing your medical
record you can have a review of your
records as well as prescription renewals
as well as a daily list of your current
medications
southwest medical patients can also
access a tab called
e-visits where they can email their
physician
and ask questions about medications or
other health-related concerns
southwest medical has locations across
southern nevada for more information
just call 702-877-5199
or visit smalv.com